à coke sat l'alchimie qui s'empare de
l'aurore relève de la magie des petits
matins du monde
il est 8 heures passées lorsque le petit
village se lève les cieux pour réveil
on s'apprête alors à y vivre le voyage
de toute une vie une course contre le
temps à extraire le sel des entrailles
de la terre
soixante dix familles vivent des travail
là en plein nulle part l'eau est pompée
à 250 mètres de profondeur dans une
vieille mais riche en sel on l'a répand
dans de grands bassins
au bout de trois jours l'eau s'est
évaporée l'or blanc
le sel apparaît le cycle renaît depuis
la nuit des temps
accompagnant la sueur du front des
générations qui se succèdent
et ces peignes 33 ans tout sourire
dehors qui nous en parlent en premier
[Musique]
ça fait plus de dix ans que je travaille
ici
j'extrais le sel est propre aux parents
comme mes ancêtres faisait ce métier
avant moi un jour une compagne est
arrivée elle a fait creuser des puits
tout s'est modernisée c'est le
propriétaire le chef de la compagnie
qu'ils nous distribuent les bassins en
fonction de la taille de la famille si
c'est une famille nombreuse beaucoup de
bassin lui seront attribués si c'est une
petite halle en or après nous on est 6
j'ai quatre enfants nous avons droit à
huit bassins et paix a trahi mais je ne
me plains pas on se fait pas mal
d'argent ça se sait beaucoup aimeraient
s'y mettre mais personne ne veut laisser
sa place
c'est une chance je gagne ma vie avec le
soleil je vis grâce au sel j'aimerais
bien que mes enfants prennent le relais
après moi je pourrais leur léguer tout
ça
10h lors de la relève certains partent
d'autres arrivent
le soleil lui n'attend pas il dessèche
tout ce qui vit on se réfugie alors à
l'ombre des hangars le sel arrive ici en
vrac caressé par une quarantaine de
femmes qui s'agitent autour de lui comme
des infirmières retour d'amour ans il
s'agrippe à la vis sans fin qui le
conduit au fond d'un sont les sauts font
des petits tas les petits tas sont mis
dans des petits sacs les petits sacs mis
dans les grands
un chef veille sur ses ouvrières c'est
lui qui compte les 5000 tonnes de sel
produite ici tous les ans je fais tout
ici je dois bien l'avouer ce que je
préfère c'est de rester assis pour
m'occuper des comptes et signer des
papiers
[Applaudissements]
à vrai dire avec le sel le travail est
toujours le même nous y sommes habitués
rien de difficile rien de facile non
plus d'ailleurs le seul aléa c'est la
nature
lorsqu'il pleut par exemple les ouvriers
doivent se précipiter pour protéger les
marais en cas d'orage il nous faut même
vous arrêter pendant un moment parfois
parce qu'on a peur sait jamais
[Musique]
à midi alors que le soleil est au zénith
et que le vent se lève
c'est l'heure de la pause l'histoire du
sel pourrait s'arrêter à une mise en sac
mais les hommes en ont décidé autrement
afin de pouvoir continuer à extraire le
sel malgré les orages et la mousson ils
ont appris avec le temps à dompter les
éléments l'eau puisée du coeur de la
terre est déversée dans des grandes
cuves rongé par les ans le bois vient
alimenter le feu qui fait office de
soleil et les alchimistes en plein coeur
de cet enfer qui frise les 45 degrés se
met même à espérer la vie autrement je
fais des voeux oui je suis chrétien je
prie le seigneur tous les jours pour que
j'obtienne davantage de salles et qu'on
vienne me l'acheter
j'ai un fils de 2 ans et 7 mois mais je
lui souhaite une autre vie je ne veux
pas qu'il souffre autant que moi pour en
arriver là
j'aimerais qu'il fasse de longues études
pour qu'ils puissent gagner beaucoup
d'argent qui a travaillé dans un bureau
le risque de ce métier c'est de tomber
dans l'eau bouillante
ils ont tombe dans les cuves mais ça
n'arrive pas tout le temps une fois tous
les quatre ou cinq mois mais pas
toujours
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire très
attention moi même j'en ai très peur
j'en ai peur comme des longs voyages le
voyage a season d'existence il est 20
heures l'heure de repartir avant que
tout ne recommence demain la sueur du
front des zones aura encore le goût du
sel
[Musique]